Alright guys so welcome to course update 4.0 this update is going to actually
make you a monster okay this update has all the advanced ICT concepts and if you
understand these concepts guys trust me you will become an independent trader
you will not need anyone else okay you will be able to identify daily bias
multi bias weekly bias you will be able to create your own model I will teach
you a couple of new strategies that are insanely profitable and insanely
powerful but let's talk about our first topic of the course update which is the
monthly weekly and daily bias now before we get into the monthly weekly daily
bias you want to know about external liquidity and internal liquidity so
over here as you can see I have marked out this high as external liquidity I've
also marked out this low as external liquidity so basically price and this
right here this fair value gap in the discount so this is the equilibrium of
this move so if you use your Fibonacci from this to this that is your
equilibrium right and below any fair value gap below that is an internal
liquidity so what market does is it market only moves in two ways okay it
either takes out external liquidity right and seeks for internal liquidity right
so market will take out external liquidity and it will the drawn
liquidity would be the fair value gap in the discount okay that is one thing
that market does and the second and the last thing that market is is it moves
from internal sorry guys it moves from internal to external right here so this
right here is an external liquidity here as well so basically we are moving from
external to internal and from internal to external I repeat again external
liquidity is any high or low and internal liquidity is any fair value gap in the
discount or premium that is what you need to know about
external and internal liquidity okay so now how do we find our let's talk about
monthly bias okay so for monthly bias we want to be using three time frames
okay and for like for weekly bias we will use two times as well and for daily we
would use three time frames as well and you will be learning a new strategy in
this video as well so keep watching okay so how do we determine the monthly
bias it's very simple you mark out the closest high or low and if you see that
prices take on an extended liquidity look below it where is the fair value gap
in the discount okay so you want to use your frame from bottom to top on the
monthly time frame first okay we go to the monthly first once price has taken
out extended liquidity now we need to have a confluence that price is not
going to reverse into internal liquidity okay we can't just simply short from
here because we have no confirmation so once you have a purge of external
liquidity on the monthly time frame you want to drop down to the daily time
frame and once you drop down to daily time frame you want to look for a market
structure shift once you have a market structure shift guys that is your
confirmation that we are gonna seek this internal liquidity okay now you have
your high time frame and now you have your daily time frame supporting that
narrative as well that we are gonna go down into the internal liquidity right
here which is the fair value gap in the discount so once you have the market
structure shift what you want to do is you can literally take your entry from
that autoblock okay that is your like simple model okay you can simply use
this as a strategy once you get a market structure shift take your entry from
here take portions along the way your main target would be here okay although
when we go into different chapters of this course update I'm gonna teach you
my specific strategies that I use with this by combining daily bias and all but
for now what we are learning is how to identify your monthly bias so once you
have a market structure shift on the daily time frame your monthly bias would
be bearish until this internal liquidity is hit now of course it's not gonna be
hit like hundred percent of the time but most of the time price will draw
into the fair value gap that is in the discount and that is unmitigated the
fair value gap has to be unmitigated okay that is very important so you have a
market structure shift right and that is pretty much your level so once you have
a market structure shift you can look for simply take your entry from the
revenue gap you can use ABC strategy you can use ABCD trading strategy you can
use whatever you want once you have a market structure shift your bias is to
the downside now your entries and executions must be on the one hour time
frame okay when you're using ABC or ABCD whatever it is I'm gonna talk about
those later but once you have a market structure shift you can take your entry
on the daily time frame as well because we got the market structure shift
surprise is gonna go down anyways right so you can take your entry from I don't
know this fairly gap over here or could be an auto block here just remember your
target is over here and similarly for weekly bias we use these time streams
for the higher time frame is gonna be one week so our high time frame is
weekly our intermediate time is like four hour and our lowest time frame is
gonna be 15 minutes so similarly what you're looking for is price to take out
some form of high or low once practice has taken out higher low on the weekly
time frame you are simply looking for a market structure shift on a four hour
time frame now the thing is price cannot keep going up right like that and then
give you a market shift you want to see like a an instant market structure shift
runs price takes out liquidity okay you can yeah so you have to train your eyes
I'm gonna show you the examples and then that would be clear on how you can you
know differentiate it so once you have like a market structure shift on the
four hour time frame you can simply take your entry from the four hour time frame
itself or you can use 15 minute time frames for other strategies but don't
worry about that I'm gonna teach you that stuff later on but what we need to
know is once you get the market structure shift your bias is now set okay
your bias for the weekly your weekly bias is gonna be bearish until the
internal liquidity is hit right here so let me show you an example how this
would look like so let's say price takes out external liquidity on the weekly
time frame you drop down to the four hour time frame you mark out any low once
price breaks that low you will get a market structure shift so you simply use
your fit from top to bottom and look for your entry above the 0.5 level okay so
there could be a fairly gap and that is a simple model okay that you can use a
strategy but there are better ones I'm gonna teach you so don't worry so right
here you can see we get a market structure shift right here over here we
take our entry we target this level this fairly gap below the 0.5 level and from
here onwards you can see we move from internal to external now moving from
internal to external is is I would say is not that high probable if that makes
sense for example if you're looking to go from internal to external that would
require you to have a very very strong bias like if the auto flow is
extremely bullish then you can look for this type of bias setup right so this
whole concept this right here even though I knew ABC right this is ABC
basically and into the fairly gap and ABC right here and then into the
fairly gap or this low here this this was simplified big shout out to the
market maker I don't know what's his name the market maker maker or
something like that on Twitter and this is a this concept is from him so I want
to give a shout out to him credit to him the market maker model I think maker I
don't know wait let me just check so I am giving the shout out to the correct
person it is basically the the market maker trader okay the MMXM trader big
shout out to him so if you want to learn this concept from the the person who
like simplified at this you can go and you know learn from here but I'm teaching
the exact same thing so basically that is pretty much it you need to know about
extended and liquid foil and for the daily bias of course we're gonna use
three time frames as well so let's say that this is the daily time frame price
takes out extended liquidity on the daily time frame right here right you
want to drop down to one hour again and then you want to look for a
market such a shift once you have a market such a shift on the hourly time
frame you can simply look for your entry on the one hour time frame okay that is
your like your simple bread and butter model you can simply use that model to
take trades okay but if you want to increase your win rate I mean I wouldn't
say win rate but if you want to increase your risk reward ratio you have to use
this this time five minutes and I will get to that later in the video in the
course okay so don't worry about it once you get the market shift as I said
before your bias is confirmed okay price will not breach this high once you get
the market structure shift so your target will be here okay but that doesn't
mean that you take your trade and you hold the whole trade until internal
liquidity is hit we don't know about markets what they're gonna do so just
just take your target at a specific level could be 1 to 2 1 to 3 right you
just need to know the direction of the market you don't want to target the
exact same location which is this okay price can simply just go come down here
and then reverse but we are setting up a revised like okay this is gonna be hit
so we're gonna trade until you know we are above so basically your entries
also entries also must be above the you know the 0.5 level here okay so
remember that so now that we have talked about all these things and
external and internal liquidity let me give you guys a couple of examples